with every single day humanity is
getting closer to the point when we can
claim with certainty that we have
profoundly studied and conquered the
nearest space objects
nevertheless the period sufficient to
fulfill this task should take rather
long to complete in terms of one human
life
and most of us will hardly be around
when the time comes for readily
available trips to the moon or mars
but apart from other celestial bodies
there is a great many of other things in
the universe that present
interest and some of them are to be
found right on our earth
right now we're about to visit some
mysterious corners of our planet
and have a look at what dangers are
concealed in the peculiar phenomenon of
permafrost
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
permafrost is the part of the upper
layer of the earth's crust
characterized by sub-zero temperatures
of rocks and soils which never thaws
the name is self-explanatory if you look
at it closer
the total area of permafrost on our
planet accounts for 35 million square
kilometers
just to compare it is 5 million more
than the area of africa
most of permafrost is to be found in the
northern parts of america
europe asia and the antarctic
interestingly there is not a speck of it
in australia
the temperature in the permafrost soils
and rocks never rises above zero
with the depth of the layer sometimes
reaching more than one thousand meters
the deepest point of permafrost is
registered in the upper waters of the
ville river in yakutia
the record deepest point is 1370 meters
down below
it takes a rather long time for a layer
of permafrost this thick to form
just to give you an idea it takes one
winter for the ground to freeze
approximately one meter deep
assuming winter never gave way to spring
the ground would freeze four meters deep
in the course of one year
however the bigger the depth the slower
the ground freezes
and it would take about a thousand years
for the layer of permafrost to reach as
deep down as 116 meters
and about a million years to reach a
depth of 700 meters
permafrost is a global large-scale
phenomenon
covering not less than 25 percent of all
land on the globe
at the same time most of permafrost
today is slowly but inexorably thawing
and this process will realistically
cause staggering damage to the world
economy
it is believed that by the end of the
21st century the thawing will have led
to damages worth 43 trillion dollars
it is the increased rate of global
warming with the destruction of the
foundations of constructions and areas
with permafrost as one of its direct
consequences that may become the chief
reason for such damage
still all this may be realistically
prevented if mankind takes necessary
measures to curb global warming and its
harmful effects
as soon as this century incidentally
this danger is not the worst that may
before humankind if permafrost melts
there are other threats lurking in
permafrost that may manifest themselves
literally
at any moment for example it may contain
frozen viruses
whose age may be tens of thousands of
years or else it may cause outbreaks of
more recent diseases like plagues of
different sorts
including siberian plague also known as
anthrax
in 2014 russian and french scientists
discovered a giant virus called
pithovirus sibericum
comparable with bacteria in terms of its
size the find was made in 30 000 year
permafrost
it proved to be viable but fortunately
wasn't dangerous for humans
the virus preferred exclusively some
kinds of amoebas to parasite on
and even the worst case scenario
wouldn't seriously affect the local
ecosystem
still such frozen finds may
theoretically cause
small scale outbreaks of diseases among
some animals
thus there may be a correlation between
occasional outbreaks of the so-called
pdv
and thawing of ice as a result thousands
of seals in the arctic
and sea otters in alaska have fallen
prey to the virus for several years with
astonishing regularity
besides in the past when there was an
outbreak of an epidemic in northern
areas
animal carcasses used to be dumped
underground
today when they thaw these burial sites
pose a grave threat to us
no pun intended diseases like a plague
may suddenly start spreading at any
moment
for example there was an outbreak of
siberian plague in 2016 in the yamal
region of the russian federation
at the time this phenomenon was largely
associated with the anomalous heatwave
that year
which caused an animal burial site to
thor with the virus escaping from its
centuries-long confinement
but it is not only siberian plague
spores that are to be found in
permafrost
for example in 2007 french scientists
unearthed microorganisms which were
still quite active
and none the worst for their age that
could be anything up to
500 000 years one more example
in 2018 some bacteria were discovered in
the interior of the frozen mammoth
mountain in yakutia
their possible age is estimated at three
and a half million years
today in every permafrost area such
prehistoric burial sites are paid close
attention to
and measures are taken to make these
territories unavailable to people
and animals outbreaks of viral
infections of this kind are
comparatively unlikely dangers
as humanity has had to cope with similar
epidemics before
but there are other secrets concealed in
permafrost
one of them is the formation of gas
hydrate fields and
in particular methane hydrate
this is a supramolecular kind of
compound consisting of methane and water
which is resistant to low temperatures
and extreme pressure
methane hydrate also known as methane
clathrate
is the most widespread gas hydrate in
nature
its fields are estimated at 10 to the
power of 16 kilograms
which is even more than global oil
reserves
these are as big as 2 times 10 to the
power of 14 kilograms
methane is known as one of several
greenhouse gases
and the result of its release could be
one of the things causing global warming
still its effect on the process is not
as serious as that of other greenhouse
gases like water vapor or carbon dioxide
the point is that methane stays in the
atmosphere only for 10 or 12 years
nevertheless if in theory methane were
to be released from all deposits in the
world
it would cause temperatures to soar and
all other hydrates to destabilize
this would unleash an irreversible
process rapidly gaining in intensity
as a reversible as a gunshot after the
trigger has been pulled
the direct result of permafrost thawing
is the release of methane into the
atmosphere
and a gradual buildup of the greenhouse
effect after that
the average temperature on the earth
will increase which will cause the
release of greenhouse gases
all over the planet this will naturally
make permafrost thaw
quicker which will lead to the
greenhouse effect gradually
but irreversibly intensifying that is
why the theory about the probability of
this event
is referred to as the clathrate gun
hypothesis
according to the original version of
this hypothesis the so-called clathrate
gun may cause sudden self-reinforcing
global warming
and it may take the process less than an
average human life to be completed
it is suggested that such decomposition
of methane hydrates may have caused
sharp changes in the global ocean and
the earth's atmosphere in the past
and mass extinction events with direct
consequences of these processes
the chief result of methane release is a
temperature increase
this is posited to be the decisive
factor of a temperature growth by 6
degrees celsius during the permian
extinction
in addition there are theories
suggesting that following methane
release
the level of available oxygen in the
atmosphere will drop
which in itself is an alarming prospect
in fact the content of co2 in the
atmosphere today has reached an all-time
high
and it keeps growing exponentially so if
this scenario were to run its course in
this manner
clathrate methane destabilization may
turn into an irreversible
self-reinforcing mechanism that would
cause temperatures to rise to dangerous
levels
as a result of a substantial and
continuous temperature increase in the
ocean
deposits lying under the bottom will
heat up to a point sufficient to start
the process of decomposition of the
deepest layers of clathrate methane
it should be mentioned that it will take
several millennia to get this process
started
recent studies in the siberian arctic
revealed that even at this point
millions of tons of methane have been
released probably due to permafrost
structures at the sea bottom
following this in some areas methane
concentration has grown hundredfold
methane release in the modern world used
to be estimated at half a megaton a year
today not less than 1400 gigatons of
carbon in the form of methane is trapped
underwater below permafrost in the
arctic
incidentally permafrost thawing would
occasionally occur in the history of our
planet
that is why some researchers claim that
the processes taking place today can
hardly be detrimental to mankind in any
way
still human impact on the environment
should be monitored at all times
and we will always have to have an eye
on our activities
and make sure that they do not grow more
and more damaging
to our nature
dear friends you must have noticed that
apart from videos about space
we also make videos about different
phenomena to be seen on our own planet
facts about our earth are not less
interesting than information we find out
about the remotest objects in space our
planet is truly fascinating
and the more people find out about its
buildup the higher the chance it will
remain habitable for many millennia to
come
if you agree feel free to confirm it by
like or a comment
or both we will greatly appreciate it
let's keep in touch
you